Let's do this.
Thanks everybody for joining this meeting.
Let me get this
so you have the slide up.
Thanks so much for everybody. This is the cardio-oncology session.
We've done this a couple of years in a row, where we focus more
on toxicology and the
cardiac side effects of drugs.
But we thought we would do something a little bit differently today.
We have three outstanding speakers, and my job
is to get out of the way so they can actually
do most of the talking.
So this is what we typically think of as
cardio-oncology. It's the explosion of
therapies that have revolutionized, on one hand,
cancer treatment,
but on the other
hand, have significant cardiovascular issues.
Some of the drugs with specific issues.
We started out with... And this concept is not entirely new.
We knew anthracyclines led to heart failure in a subset of
patients 50 years ago.
What's been more surprising are the advent of novel targeted
therapies,
which have specific cardiac issues.
And so this is actually how most of our clinics run.
The clinic I run now at UCSF
is focused on helping these patients overcome some of
these
cardiac issues, especially for them to stay on
these very potentially life-saving therapies.
The other pitch I wanted to make quickly is, as a physician
scientist and as somebody who runs a basic science lab, the
specific targeted therapies that we have for oncology
now, and the cardiac issues that come about from
them, can give us potentially insights into cardiovascular
biology, which unlike many diseases that we think
about in cardiology, starts at the patient level.
The fact that VEGF inhibitors, for example, lead to
hypertension, proteinuria, and cardiomyopathy, has led
to better understanding and the signaling,
not
just for these patients, but as many people know, the signaling
becomes critically important in pregnant women who
have cardiovascular issues, including preeclampsia and
peripartum cardiomyopathy. And so this list goes on with
many other therapies. For us at UCSF, this has
led to a number of physician scientists,
lab-based scientists or physicians as well, who are in this space.
I'm proud to say one of the new fellows we have is Ricky Baylis, who's a
vascular biologist trained by Nick Leeper.
We're lucky to recruit their phenomenal physician scientists.
He actually did the PhD with Gary Owens.
But the list goes on. So this is one part we're not going to talk about,
but I think it's also important to know the toxicology is still
the backbone of how we think about the clinic.
So this is a paper I wrote with Katherine Moore, who's one of our
speakers, and Qin Zhang,
one of my colleagues at UT Southwestern, who's an oncologist,
basic cancer biologist. And it really touches on what
we're going to talk about today, which is beyond the cancer
drug effects or cancer effects on the heart.
I should mention, I talked a little bit earlier about cancer treatments
and toxicities, but cancers themselves can
have cardiovascular issues. We know this on a
subset of patients who get amyloid from
plasma cell dyscrasias or carcinoid heart disease
from neuroendocrine tumors.
But I think the concepts we're going to talk about include, first,
this growing appreciation that many
common risk factors predispose not just to
cardiovascular disease,
but also cancer. And we know this for many
years with certain things like smoking.
We knew many years ago
that if you smoke, you have a higher chance of having lung cancer, but
also having cardiovascular disease.
I'm proud to say one of the papers that really made me think this was
Donald McDonald's 2014 science
paper that showed very nicely, following up on
years of epidemiologic data, that high cholesterol,
something that we think about as a critical cardiovascular risk
factor, is also an important risk factor
for estrogen receptor-positive breast cancer.
That's 60% of breast cancers that exist out there.
That same year, end of 2014, came Ben
Ebert's now classic paper on somatic
mutations in the form of CHIP or clonal hematopoiesis,
that we have known for many years is a risk factor for
hematologic malignancies and other malignancies, but he nicely
showed in the seminal "New England Journal of Medicine" paper that it's a risk
factor for cardiovascular disease.
Depending on the mutations, for example, TET2 mutations now,
we think of CHIP as on par with diabetes in some
cases as an independent risk factor for cardiovascular
disease. And the list goes on now with obesity, where we
have this interesting observation that novel
obesity drugs
in cardiovascular frontline trials, the secondary
outcome, which is overall survival, is often
higher... difference than what you see in the primary outcome, which we
never see in cardiovascular trials, and this in part
may be because of the cancer effects but other disease effects.
There were a series of papers that came out, and here I'm going to
embarrass Katherine Moore and Nick Leeper a little bit
about this idea of reverse cardio-oncology.
The fact that cardiovascular disease itself
can potentiate cancer itself, and you're going to hear a great
talk
by Nick Leeper
on this, as well as Katherine
Moore.
The last thing I want to bring up, and that's when I get off the
stage, is this idea that there are common risk
factors or how cancer
affects the heart or heart affects the cancer is critically
important for all of us, right? The number one and the number
two cause of death by far, at least in the US, is
cardiovascular disease and cancer.
Number three is far behind those two.
We have about 700,000 Americans every year
that die of cardiovascular disease.
600,000, give or take, who die of all forms of
cancer. And number three on the list is 100,000, right?
So those are by far the major drivers of mortality in
the US and I would argue in the entire world.
So the fact that you can potentially treat these underlying risk
factors can be potentially really important.
But the one population I want to focus on are the cancer
survivors.
In the US,
because of the advent of new therapies in oncology, this whole meeting
is based on that. We have a growing number of cancer
survivors. We have 20 million Americans now who are cancer
survivors. That's 6% of the population.
We have
4 million Americans who are breast cancer survivors,
close to 4 million who are prostate cancer survivors, just to give some
specificities. We always think of recurrence of
cancer as a major public
health issue for those patients. But for many cancer
survivors, cardiovascular disease remains the number
one cause of death. And that's a really important concept,
especially as we think about these common risk factors.
I used to always think people have cardiovascular disease
once they're cancer survivors, possibly because of these
treatments that they get.
But I think one of the concepts I want you to think about after the great talks
we're about to hear is that maybe it's the common risk
factors. And if you think about this, this central
concept has an important thing for us to think about
for our patients. We're going to hear a lot about great
science, but one of the ideas I want to also push
forward is what can we do for our patients?
And so I happen to be the only cardiologist who's part of this
NCCN network, which is a national guidelines
network for how we
give chemo A versus chemo B for various cancers.
I bounce around between the two groups depending on what their needs
are. But one group that we helped form is a survivorship group.
And one concept that we introduced is this ABCDE
steps of cardiovascular health. If you look at this
closely, a lot of these are classic cardiovascular risk
factors that we always think about treating.
But if you think about this concept I introduced, that some of these risk
factors like cholesterol, like diet, like diabetes, like
exercise, if you
are not only drivers for cardiac disease but also cancer,
for every cancer survivor to follow these steps, it has
huge public health implications for them specifically,
beyond just the general population.
So at least this has been one effort by the cancer
community to focus on these areas.
And so with that, I would stop. This has helped us have a
growing program at UCSF that helps take care of
cancer patients, but also cancer survivors.
But with that, I'll stop and have our speakers go.
So Donald McDonald, I've actually met him for the first time.
He was one of the
inspirations for me to be in this space, with the science
paper that I mentioned in 2014. So Donald, I'll
let you.
Thank you very much.
So thank you for the opportunity to come and speak.
Normally, I come to the ACR. I speak about the primary research
program in my lab, which is development of drugs to treat metastatic breast
cancer. But what you're going to see from my talk today is
that the expertise that we had gained in studying estrogen receptor
in breast cancer led us to an interesting convergence between
cardiovascular biology and also cancer biology.
And I think that it really fits very well into the theme that Javid has put today,
and that is cardiovascular disease impacts cancer and
cancer impacts cardiovascular disease.
So, this is a slide that has been well-worn.
I had it in a review about 10 years ago.
But to be honest with you, the seminal messages from this slide remain.
It is clear that obesity itself, in and of itself, is a risk
factor, of course, not only for cardiovascular disease, but
also it impacts definitely the incidence of
many different cancers, especially cancers of the female
reproductive tract like breast, ovarian, and
particularly endometrial. And in fact, in endometrial cancer, it's thought
that up to 20% of all those cancers can be attributed
back to obesity and the sequelae associated with
obesity.But what is interesting is when you look at this, is
that we have very good basic science that links
obesity through, if you want, the well-fed state, either
triglycerides or sugar, to increases in
production of IGF-1, which is a well-known
promoter of breast cancer growth.
We also know that hyperinsulinemia from dysregulated
glucose metabolism also affects breast cancer, likely by very similar
pathways. And then this is very much of a black box.
Adipose tissue in the wrong place definitely impacts cancer
biology, not only because of the classical responses, that is in
production of inflammatory cytokines, but also, as many of you probably
know, the primary site for extragonadal production of
estrogens is, in fact, adipose tissue.
It's a pathological feature of adipose tissue that really
nobody has any idea why it's produced there, and it's actually the
primary reason that aromatase inhibitors are effective in
the treatment of breast cancer patients, either in the prevention, the adjuvant, or
the treatment setting, is because it's reducing the production of extragonadal
estrogens.
So why is a guy here who works on the estrogen receptor talking about
cholesterol?
And the reason is, as I said, both of these fields converged in my lab.
As I said, I do want to introduce you to this because it'll help you understand the
first part of the talk, and that is how
cholesterol and dyslipidemia impacts ER-positive cancers.
But what I think is even more surprising, and I think very surprising, is
the impact and the mechanism by which hypercholesterolemia affects not
only estrogen receptor-positive breast cancers, but cancers in
general.
So again, just to remind you for the first few slides, the estrogen receptor is a
ligand-dependent transcription factors.
Its role in the
growth and progression of breast cancer is well established, and
the majority of breast cancer, about 70%
of them, whether they're in the early or late setting, at least the initial
therapies are endocrine therapies which target the estrogen receptor.
So this was of interest to me because... Let me back up.
My group had not only developed drugs to inhibit the estrogen receptor, but we'd
also developed this whole concept of functional allostery, and that
is different ligands could bind to the receptor, drive the receptor into
different shapes, and you get different biologies.
And that led to the development of a series of molecules called SERMs, selective
estrogen receptor modulators. Tamoxifen is not an antagonist,
it's a SERM, because sometimes it functions as an agonist, sometimes it functions
as an antagonist. And so it was that hat on, if you want.
I had that hat on when I saw this paper by a very good colleague, a friend of mine,
David Mangelsdorf, who unfortunately passed away last year.
David was at UT Southwest, and he's very much interested in bile acid
receptors. And so he had a side project in the lab
looking at
agents that would modulate bile acid receptors, and a control he had in
the assay was the estrogen receptor.
And to make a very long story short, he published a fantastic paper in "Nature
Medicine" that basically showed that this molecule, which I had never heard
of before, 27-hydroxycholesterol, had some
characteristics that suggested that it might actually bind the estrogen
receptor and manifest some of the
pathobiology of this oxyesterol.
Well, we got interested in this, a young graduate student of mine.
This is going back now nearly 20 years ago.
I promise you I'm going to show you more recent data.
Which basically we asked the question, was David right?
Was this, in fact, A, an estrogen receptor modulator?
B, was it a SERM? And C, did it have any role
in breast cancer pathobiology?
So Carolyn, who, as I said, was a graduate student at the time, set up a very
simple assay. It's a transcription assay to read out on estrogen
receptor activity. And what you can see is here is that this is looking on the
y-axis at the normalized response, and this is dose of the input drugs.
This is estradiol activating transcription beautifully.
This is 27-hydroxycholesterol shifted over by about
three logs or so,
functioning as a very weak, if you want, or less potent estrogen.
But it's a classical partial agonist because if you take the 100%
activation of the estrogen receptor and you add increasing concentration to
27HC, you inhibit back down to its 100% level.
Now, before everyone gets up and leaves the room and says, "Ah, God, this is so
low," it turns out this is well within the circulating limits
of 27-hydroxycholesterol. I'll show you that in a minute.
And then again, this is on classical target genes, showing that it functions as
estradiol or functions as a pure agonist.
27-hydroxycholesterol is a partial agonist.
And if you knock out the estrogen receptor, you lose all of those
responses. So this was interesting to us because it said that
possibly 27-hydroxycholesterol could be an
endogenous SERM. Now, I'm just going to jump forward and tell you something, that
after we published our first paper on this, I got a call from a guy called Michael
Baker, who's a comparative evolutionary biologist at
UCSD, and he said, "Well, you clearly don't read my papers because we have been
talking about 27HC as a vestigial estrogen for
years." And so I said, "Well, where did you publish that?" And he said, "Oh, it's
in 'The Journal of Entomology.'" That's not one of the ones I read very often, so I
apologize for missing that. But the bottom line was is that there was some evidence
that this actually was a vestigial estrogen.
So where it comes from, it's actually
produced in a stoichiometric manner by the actions of this
macrophage-expressed enzyme called CYP27A1
into 27-hydroxycholesterol. And David Russell, in
collaboration with Brown and Goldstein, figured out what this molecule did about 20
years ago in the cholesterol biosynthesis pathway.
It actually works as a feedback mechanism to inhibit HMG CoA
reductase to basically tell the cell, you've made enough cholesterol.
It's a negative feedback. It basically works as a direct inhibitor of HMG CoA
reductase, but it also blocks the activation of the SREBPs.
And so
Eric Nelson, who's now a faculty member in
IllinoisAt the University of Illinois.
Basically, when he was a graduate or a postdoc in my lab, made a mouse where he
knocked out CYP27A1, this regulatory
enzyme. And when he went-- I beg your pardon. I'm going to go back. Sorry.
I'm sorry. I'll tell you that in a second.
I forgot where-- I changed the slides this morning. Sorry, I want to go back here.
So 27HC. I want to nail down one other point first, and that is I
made a statement that I need to provide some background to, and that is that
27-hydroxycholesterol is stoichiometrically related,
if you want, to HDL and LDL cholesterol.
And so this study was done in collaboration with Signe Borquist in Aarhus
University in Denmark and her graduate student,
Sika Gimberg. And what they did was they worked with us.
We developed a radioimmunoassay for
27-hydroxycholesterol. And what we found was is that, with phenomenal
R-squared values, that there was a great correlation between total cholesterol,
LDL cholesterol, and 27HC.
The classic test of whether this is important in cancer is to go and take
a tumor xenograft model and ask, will this drug support the
growth of a tumor? In our field, this is the gold standard
test for something to be important or not.
So this is just, I'm not going to go through this in very much detail because it's
quite simple. This is a tumor that is growing, an estrogen receptor-positive tumor
in a mouse growing with estradiol.
If I come along and I add in 27-hydroxycholesterol, the tumor grows.
If I continue it on
27-hydroxycholesterol, the tumor continues to grow.
If I block it with a pure antagonist of the estrogen receptor, I can attenuate
this. If I withdraw the 27HC at this point, the tumors will
regress. So by the criteria others and we have
established as
required to claim something to have functional estrogenic activity,
this molecule does. And so back then to that experiment that I jumped to,
and that was that Eric went and said, "Well, if that's true, I should be able to
genetically manipulate the levels of 27HC, and rather
than now using xenograft models, I'm going to use
syngeneic models of breast cancer." And so as most people know, there
are very few good models of ER-positive breast cancer.
The MMTV-PyMT model is the best one.
And you can see here is that when Eric knocked out this enzyme genetically, now
this was a whole body knockout, I will tell you, we get exactly
the same thing if we just do a macrophage-specific knockout.
So that's the primary point of conversion of cholesterol to
27HC. But you can see here that if you just look at absolute tumor
volume, that the knockout alone of this particular enzyme
decreases the growth of these tumors.
If you look at tumor latency, because this is a genetic model, you
can see that tumor latency in the knockout mouse is dramatically delayed,
and survival is dramatically improved in these mice.
Now, I'm not going to tell you right now, but it turns out that
27-hydroxycholesterol is metabolized by another enzyme called
CYP7B1. And what we did was when we knocked out that
enzyme, 27HC builds up in the animals, and you get
exactly the same, the expected response.
Tumors appear faster and grow faster.
And so what this basically then suggested to us was is that
27HC, which was, as I said, Brown and Goldstein and David
Russell had figured out to be a negative regulator of HMG
CoA reductase and to basically be a part of a negative feedback
loop that limits production of cholesterol, is in fact an
estrogen receptor modulator. In our early writings then, what we
said was, this was a paradox, because if you have something that's going to
inhibit a molecule that's required for cancer cell biology, how is
it then that it actually promotes the growth of tumors?
And we had a hand-waving answer
that I think we know a bit much more and we have better support for right now,
is that the effects of the estrogen override the effects of
the negative feedback. And I'll tell you why that happens in a few
minutes. So the bottom line is that we were about to finish the
study and walk away. We had proven that 27-hydroxycholesterol was
related with respect to levels of cholesterol.
We'd shown that it was an estrogen receptor modulator.
We'd been able to publish several papers on various mechanisms of this, and we're
ready to move on.
And basically just say, "Mission accomplished.
We've made a link between hypercholesterolemia and ER-positive breast
cancers."
However, I had a postdoc in the lab, Wen Liu.
And Wen was very much interested in literature, which also said that
dyslipidemia was associated with increased risk of triple-negative
breast cancer. And we basically had no explanation as to
why this could be, because everything we had done was focused on
the estrogen receptor. And so she made these models, which to
be honest with you, she did them on the side because I probably would never have
supported this project. It took too long and just seemed like a bit of a
hair-brained idea to me. But what she did was, she
realized that 27HC, as I told you, is a negative regulator of cholesterol
biosynthesis, and everything that we had ever done in the lab shown that in
estrogen receptor-negative cells, it inhibited the growth of those cells.
Exactly as you'd expect it. You shut down cholesterol biosynthesis, cells don't
like it, and they don't progress.
But what actually Wen found was is that if you basically let them sit
there for about a month, you let these cells sit in the presence of
27HC, what happens is subclones grow out,
and the subclones are unbelievably resistant to the
effects of 27HC. So for instance, here is a model of melanoma,
for instance, and you can see that 27HC really does not inhibit the growth of
these melanoma cells. These are two different breast cancer models.
You see 27HC inhibiting these, and you look again in the resistant cells, nothing
happens. Well, that was okay, but I just told you
27HC is part of a negative feedback loop.
And so we said, "Well, Wen, that's not a surprise.
You've just found a mutation in the negative feedback." It turns out she didn't.
It turns out that the negative feedback loop, shown here by gene expression
analysis, was intact. This is the sensitive cells.
These are all the enzymes that should have been inhibited by 27HC, and they
are. Here's in the resistant cells, and they're still inhibited in both models.
So there was something else going on.But what really got my
attention was the next model, the next experiment.
This, to me, is probably one of the most dramatic results, bar none, I've
ever seen in my lab. These are tumors.
These are all isogenic lines. And all I've
done is selected out for subclones within a
population of breast cancer cells, the PY230 model,
4T1 model, and then this is another breast cancer model, and
this is a melanoma model. Look at this. These are animal studies.
These cells, if you inject them into mice, it takes forever for them to
grow. Look how tumorigenic they were. Look at these ones, 4T1.
These are incredibly tumorigenic.
Now remember, all I have done is grown-- Actually, I said that wrong.
All Wen did was grow these cells in the presence of
27-hydroxycholesterol, and she's now made these cells
unbelievably tumorigenic. And I hope you're impressed
by this slide because before I finish, I'm going to show you another slide, which
I'm going to say is even more dramatic and more important than this.
So
what Wen wanted to do then was ask the question, if these cells are
more tumorigenic,
are they more metastatic? Now, for us in the cancer field, as you know, that's more
important to look at because the best cure for a primary tumor is a surgeon's
knife, and it's metastases that get you.
And it turns out that these cells are incredibly tumorigenic.
It's funny, these
cancer cells are labeled with luciferase, and you can see in the sensitive
lines when you inject them in the tail vein, none of these form metastatic
lesions. But if you inject the isogenic resistant
versions, they all form metastatic lesions.
The luciferase assay just doesn't do this justice because actually all you need to
do is look at the lungs from these animals.
You can see here lovely pink lungs with very few little nodules, and these things
look like walnuts. Just incredible.
And I'm going to say, this is not just one line.
This was every line we ever looked at.
And so the question then became was, how is this happening?
And so it was interesting because remember I just told you that
27-HC inhibits the production of
cholesterol.
It also blocks the activation of SREBP 1 and 2.
And so the question was, how could these cells possibly survive?
It turns out what they're doing is they are dramatically taking up lipids.
Okay? And you can see that these are the sensitive and the resistant versions of
all of these lines, and this is the quantitation out here.
They're basically non-selectively taking up lipids.
Turns out that, of course, they're taking up cholesterol, but they're taking up
mono and polyunsaturated acids. They're just sucking up anything they can get.
They're stressed out of their minds.
And so the reason that that was disappointing was because we couldn't
narrow it down to one specific transporter that was
upregulated. But that was one thing.
But the second thing is, when you have a bright postdoc, they see something like
this, and they come up with an explanation as to why it could be linked to the
biology. I never heard of a process called ferroptosis.
Never heard of it until we started doing this.
And it turns out, as most of you know, that if you take palmitate, the
fatty acid, and you put it on the cells, they die, and they die because of
ferroptosis. Okay? It's a process that occurs
because the lipids are taken into the cell.
They form these lipid oxides, which are incorporated into membranes, which
basically kills the cells. So why do cells survive that?
Well, it turns out there's a molecule called GPX4 that's in the
cell that is actually a gatekeeper, one of the gatekeepers for
ferroptosis.
And it turns out that we found that the cells that I've
told you are incredibly tumorigenic and incredibly metastatic, it
turns out that these cells, the
sensitive cells, I beg your pardon, are incredibly resistant to GPX4
inhibitors. So look at this. You don't need a red laser
pointer to separate these curves.
What you can see clearly is that the selection for cells
in the presence of 27-hydroxycholesterol that survive
makes them incredibly
resistant to ferroptosis. And why is that important?
Well, it turns out that we made a discovery, which, as I said, I think is the
most important one, and that is that the protection against
ferroptosis,
I was going to say seems to be that or at least a major
contributor to the increased
metastatic activity of cells. Look at this.
These are the PY230 cells. Again, this is
27-hydroxycholesterol sensitive, and this is the isogenic resistant lines.
You can see, as I told you before, that the resistant lines are dramatically
more metastatic than the sensitive lines.
But if I come along and I actually knock out GPX4, I completely
wipe out that phenotype.
Conversely, we showed in this paper, which probably about a year and a half ago, we
showed if you actually overexpress GPX4, you
completely
restore the activity
of the knockdown. So this is clearly on target.
And then finally, this is one of the most
aggressive models of melanoma. And
the metastasis was so bad here we had to come up with a grading scale.
So you can see all we need to do is count black nodules, and you can
see here that we developed this grading scale from really, really nasty
to pretty clean lungs. This is the sensitive cells, and this is the resistant
cells. And all you need to see is that if you come along in these
cells and you basically knock out GPX4, that what you do is you
shift the grade from right to left, and you basically
completely reduce the level of this metastatic
lesion. And so finally, I want to just put in one or two slides as to
what I can do about this. I've convinced you, I hope, that
27-hydroxycholesterol by two distinct mechanisms, one
function is an estrogen receptor modulator and also by
inducing the induction of the
GPX4, makes cancer cells much more
metastatic.My dad used to say, "You don't have a pro--,"
he's an engineer. He used to always say, "You can't complain about something unless
you have a potential solution." And so we've got two solutions.
One is take your statin. Okay? And so in this study we did with
Zica Kimberg, we actually did a study in breast cancer patients.
And what we showed was, is that those patients on a-- this was actually on
torvastatin. We actually could lower LDL
cholesterol and also lower 25-hydroxycholesterol.
And this was done in an eight-week period, so you can do that.
And then the last one, which was kind of bizarre, was a study that was done by
David Feldman's group in Stanford.
David is a good friend of mine, and he was intrigued by our work and went with a
clinical fellow. And actually, they had realized that
CYP27A1, which is the enzyme that converts cholesterol into
27-hydroxycholesterol, is very structurally similar to the enzyme
that detoxifies vitamin D, that turns over vitamin D.
And so he had a hypothesis that vitamin D would actually inhibit the action of
CYP27A1, which it did in vitro. And then he went into patients, and they
did a study. And the bottom line was is they showed that there was a
very good correlation between 25 D3-- sorry, this is not D3.
This is 25-hydroxycholesterol. Sorry.
25-hydroxyvitamin D levels and
27HC. So that the higher the vitamin D supplementation, the greater
the effect on 27HC.
So in summary, what I've told you is we've got a new arm here to the links
between obesity, dyslipidemia, and breast cancer pathology.
And also, what I hoped I told you is that the newer insights
say that this impact extends beyond breast cancer.
And the new arm is that obesity, obviously obesity in and of
itself, through production of adipokines and such as I've told you before,
also definitely impacts cancer. But now the dyslipidemia secondary
to hypercholesterolemia leads to the production of 27HC.
And I hope that I've convinced you that 27HC is pathologic.
And I hope I've also convinced you that there are ways then to manipulate it.
The simplest one is take your
statin. And the second is, it looks like that vitamin D
supplementation, which pretty much everyone in this room probably takes every
evening, is also leading to a decrease in that.
So thank you very much for your attention.
I hope that this spurs some conversations and some questions.
And as I said, I really have enjoyed being the ambassador for the students and
fellows in my lab who did this work. Thank you very much.
You can take some questions-
Okay.
-now and/or-
Yeah.
Yeah. A couple of minutes.
Thank you very much for your talk.
Thank you.
Farzaneh Masoud from University of Illinois.
I work at the Illinois Fire Service Institute.
And as a cancer researcher, I found out that not that many cancer
researchers actually know about the health challenges that
firefighters are facing. So number one cause
of death among firefighters is cancer, followed very closely by
cardiovascular disease.
So we have a longitudinal study that we are looking at their cholesterol,
we are looking at the visceral fat, we are looking at their liver enzyme.
And it seemed to be very much correlated with the level of
toxicity and exposure that they are receiving, like
PFOS exposures, polycyclic aromatic
hydrocarbons-
Yeah.
-and now with the electric vehicles, the heavy
metals-
Yeah.
-that there are. So
not that many people know about it, not that many people publish in
this field. But
mainly because like IARC, and
group, they don't know the
mechanistic evidence or correlation.
Yeah.
So I wonder if you have any idea if this can
be a way to actually demonstrate
that's the cause?
Yeah. So, I think the models, definitely.
The models we've used can definitely be used.
You
gave me a long list of compounds that you think are impacting, and they all
have different mechanism actions.
I think we know a lot about aryl hydrocarbon receptor agonists and antagonists from
the work of Steve Safe. They definitely do increase
cancer risk, but they also increase the progression of cancers that
are already malignant.
The other one is things like PFOS and things like
that. There are lots of hypotheses that they work through
nuclear receptors, right? Estrogen and androgen receptors.
I was actually a little bit skeptical of that data. Not skeptical of the data.
The data is the data. Skeptical of the mechanism until a paper we published last
year, which basically shows that very low levels of androgens
below the level that we would've expected to activate classical transcription,
drive proliferative responses. If you want to look at Safi et al.
is the paper, and that might provide a mechanism for some of those.
But I think the last point you made is very true, is that I could
stand up here, for instance, and tell you, "Lower your cholesterol," till I go blue
in the face.
Until I tell you about a mechanism.
When you have a mechanism, people then are much more willing to accept it
as being important. This is the same in osteoporosis, the same
thing. Until some time, people had a mechanism as to explain how,
why estrogens work, people were not likely to use them.
So your point is well taken.
Yes, I'll make a comment. I'm
a second opinion medical oncology
consultant
and
science trains, NIH, and all that.
But one of the observations that I've noticed, particularly in the
last five years that we've been doing our work,
is at a very practical level, almost
a tunnel vision approach to taking care of cancer patients
or other specialties, that instead of looking at
the multiple interactions of comorbid medical issues such as your
cardiovascular situation-I would say the majority of
practicing and academic oncologists do
not look at the other medical comorbid
issues that patients have, which at least the science
seems to
go back to the old Hippocrates comment that how do you
treat a cancer patient if you don't understand the basic
patient?
Yeah.
So you've got the science on one end, but the
actual practical application's not really-
Yeah
... moving forward.
So I think you have a very good one. I will just add to your comment by saying that
there's two things we're looking at here.
What is the link between
obesity, dyslipidemia, and incidence of breast cancer, our cancers?
That's one thing. That's a harder thing to study.
But what is absolutely, I think the data is very
solid, is that for patients who have an established
disease, outcomes are much better when
dyslipidemia is controlled. That study from
several Danish groups, and also there's a couple of groups-- Well,
it's mainly the Danish groups and their registry studies that have shown that
the outcomes in breast cancer patients who have controlled lipidemia,
lipids biology, are much better than those who are not.
The numbers are staggeringly different.
So I think that comes back to your point, is that consider the cancer patient
holistically, not just the disease. Oh.
Related question. The effect of the
statin or something like that drugs on breast cancer
survival-
Yeah
... different between the ER status?
Is it different between ER status?
Yes. What is the ER-
No. It's interesting. The answer
was, the studies that were done in Denmark basically said that
all cancers were like-- and there were some obviously
ER-positive breast cancers were highly represented in that
all. All cancers, the outcome in all cancers were better in patients
who had regulated dyslipidemia. To be honest with you, I'm glad we brought that
point. When I pivoted from studying ER-positive to ER-negative
cancer and added in a few other cancers, it was because of the results of the
Danish SEER study, because we couldn't explain all of the studies based on
estrogen receptor alone. Yeah, thank you.
Thank you very much.
I'm just going to have people introduce themselves.
Nick Leeper, I've known for 20-plus years now.
It
just tells you how old I am. He's a professor at Stanford, great
colleague, great friend. He's been one of the people really
instrumental into us thinking about cancer and
heart disease bi-directionally. So, Nick.
Well, thank you, Javid, and thank you for coming to this session.
It's really a pleasure to get to be a cardiologist presenting at an oncology
conference and to follow that wonderful discussion,
and help extend the
data that we've been looking at, trying to link these two leading killers.
What I'd like to do for the next few minutes is to expand on what
Donald just started to talk about, about the link between cancer and cardiovascular
disease,
not only from the shared risk factor perspective, but also some emerging data
about the co-prevalence of these two diseases.
I'll then share some observations that we've been making about the overlapping
mechanisms that seem to be occurring in both disorders.
And then move to some unpublished data, which will look at a potential
direct causal relationship between the two diseases,
suggesting that one disease may actually directly drive the other, and the
concept that this could allow some opportunities for us to identify
new translational targets that could shift the field from a
reactive to a proactive mindset.
But what I'd really like to do is really change the thinking about considering
these two diseases as completely separate entities,
and entertain the idea that they may have much more in common than we
previously appreciated.
We've been well aware, and we've heard about the
public health impact of these two leading killers.
And I think that there's been so much talk over the years about the
co-occurrence of shared risk factors that has led
people to think that these just are going to naturally co-occur, until
we started to hear the type of data that Donald talked about just now with
dyslipidemia and obesity.
We and others have begun to note that there seems to be more of a co-prevalence
that's increasing with time, and the idea that these aren't just co-occurring, but
if you've had one disease, you may be at higher risk of subsequently developing the
other.
The first work that I read came out of a heart failure population where
they found that these individuals were much more likely to go on to develop a range
of malignancies.
This paper was provocative but was quite limited, due to an inability to
control for co-founders, including smoking.
But since then, other groups have really expanded on this, including a beautiful
study from Japan showing that people with different forms of
cardiovascular disease are at higher risk of cancer.
And then a report from Canada showing the opposite to be true, and that various
forms of malignancy put you at higher risk of heart disease.
Now, these papers were a big advance, but they had their own limitations.
And so, our group set out to try to use large claim
data sets to expand these findings.
And leveraging data for more than 30 million individuals, we
found this interesting observation that
non-atherosclerotic forms of disease, like valve disease or
arrhythmia, do not appear to put you at higher risk of
cancer.But there's a rather specific association with
atherosclerotic forms. And because of our power, we were
able to resolve these relationships with a wide range of
individual malignancies.
And because we had access to a large number of different datasets with
more and less information about comorbidities, we were able to find that
these patterns would persist even when we did the best we could to
adjust for other confounding factors like obesity,
diabetes, smoking, et cetera.
Now, we've got some ongoing work in the lab, some of it's published, some of it's
coming out soon, showing that this will extend to other types of
cardiovascular disease. I'm a vascular medicine doctor.
I take care of PAD. We've seen the same association with this
disease. We've found that patients with aortic aneurysms are
also at higher risk of developing malignancy.
And there seems to be a gene dosage type effect in people that have
atherosclerosis affecting multiple vascular beds, seem to
have a stepwise increase in this relationship with
cancer. And I think that to Donald's point,
this does have potentially clinical relevance, and
we've begun to identify associations not with the presence of cancer,
but also metastatic cancer. And so there may come a time in the
future where getting diagnosed with heart disease may be a
threshold where you might offer screening for
mammography or colonoscopy at a younger age so that you can
avoid having these late diagnoses which will present with
metastasis.
And then finally, Donald already started to allude to this about lipid lowering.
But there is a concept that addressing all of the known cardiovascular risk factors
may have benefit. This has been shown by several groups, and we
recently published a meta-analysis.
And this would suggest that if you can take care of the
Life's Essential Eights, which are the risk factors that the American
Heart Association tells us to work on for heart disease, that you
may enjoy as much as a 50% reduction in developing
cancer down the road.
So at least food for thought about public health initiatives.
But what I wanted to talk about today is if this field should move
beyond shared risk factors and start to focus on this
concept of overlapping biological mechanisms.
And this is a topic that our lab has been thinking about, amongst
many others now, for more than a decade.
And I won't have time to go through all of the considerations that we've started to
notice. But I wanted to point out a few because I think they're pretty provocative.
Our lab is really heavy on using unbiased human genetics, and
anybody that's followed these GWAS stories over the year will
know that to this day, the head and shoulders most
important thing that you can inherit from your parents that will put you at risk
for having a myocardial infarction are the variants at chromosome
9p21. And this just floored me when these papers
were published because these loci are not in lipid
metabolism or blood pressure or smoking or diabetes
loci. This is actually in the well-known tumor suppressor
locus for p15 or CDKN2B, suggesting that the most
important thing that puts you at higher genetic risk for heart disease has
nothing to do with our traditional risk factors, but instead may relate
to cell cycle regulation.
Javed told us about clonal hematopoiesis, which is one of the more fascinating
discoveries of the last decade from Sid Jaiswal and Ben Ebert and others,
which, as Javed mentioned, is a well-known pattern where these
somatic mutations will put you at higher risk for hematological malignancies.
But there's an even greater impact on your risk of atherosclerotic disease,
which Javed mentioned is on the order of diabetes and I think may be as high
as smoking, suggesting that, wow, what an important
risk factor that we weren't aware of that yet again hearkens back to
biology that's probably classically more associated with the field of
oncology than cardiology.
Our lab has also thought a lot about this concept of the cancer stem
cell and this idea that this may be the mechanism by which you can have
an initial tumor induction and remission, and then
the cancer will recur years or decades later and often is
widely metastatic.
We and others have begun to use multicolor lineage tracers, and at
least in mouse models, we see that diseases like
atherosclerosis clearly have a clonal component
that is very reminiscent of the cancer stem cell hypothesis.
So again, this idea that there may be such a thing as an
atherosclerotic stem cell that will behave in a very similar fashion.
And then one of the main areas that our lab works on is this concept
of failed efferocytosis. And this is really a
concept that we borrowed from the oncology field, where tumor
cells will upregulate what are known as don't eat me molecules
that will help them escape the tumoricidal macrophage.
And then our lab has shown that the exact same pathways are turned on in
atherosclerosis, and we have begun to hypothesize that this
may be what allows these cells to
escape the immune surveillance, not be removed by
the macrophages in the plaque, and then that this will allow the plaque to
expand, causing coronary disease, very similar to why
the cancer is allowed to grow.
And then, I think to Donald's point, you can't just complain about it.
You have to have a solution for it.
We have taken advantage of this overlapping link between cancer and heart
disease to pursue integrated genomics.
And when we blend the datasets, we can start to identify patterns that may
be mutually detrimental. And then we can filter these through
drug repurposing algorithms to try to find medicines that may one day be able to
help both diseases very similar to what we just heard about with
statins.But
for today, what I really want to do is move from just these
associations to actual causation and
start to ask the question of whether having one disease may
induce some systemic changes that can then circulate throughout the
body to lead to an increase in the other disease or vice versa.
And I think if any of you are curious about whether having heart disease can
produce cancer,
you're in for a treat today because our next speaker is one of the world's
experts on this concept. And so stay tuned for a great story
about this that I'm looking forward to hearing.
But for my part today, I want to share some unpublished work
from a really talented person sitting here in the room, Lingfeng Luo,
who is one of the junior faculty colleagues at Stanford.
And he has been working on this really fantastic project trying
to understand if cancer may directly accelerate
atherosclerosis. And I'll point out that he's going to give a more full description
of this work on Tuesday morning.
So Lingfeng set out to ask a very simple question about whether implanting
tumors in mice can directly accelerate
atherosclerosis. And when he did this, he found that yes,
if you implant colon cancers into the flank of a mouse, you will have
a modest increase in that plaque size.
But for those that look at these types of experiments, you'll note that this is not
a dramatic increase in the overall size of the plaque.
What was different, though, was the characteristics of the plaque.
And in contrast to the control mice, which have very
little neovessels growing into the lesion and very little
intraplaque hemorrhage, Lingfeng noted that the
mice that were bearing tumors had plaques that were really
riddled with these new neovessels that were growing in.
And what he found was that these appeared to be fragile and were prone to rupture,
which you can see here with this red cell stain.
And regardless of the way that he quantified this, he saw that there was this
plaque vulnerability phenotype.
And from the cardiologist perspective, we think this matters because these
plaque hemorrhages can destabilize the plaque and then
ultimately lead to the plaque rupture that will lead to heart attack or stroke,
thereby talking about its clinical significance.
Lingfeng wanted to understand the mechanism by which cancer was promoting
atherosclerosis. And so to do this, I'm going to briefly
summarize a couple of years' worth of work.
But Lingfeng implanted a wide range of tumors into mouse
models and then harvested their vasculature for RNA sequencing.
What he found was that the common pathways that were turned on were all, again,
related to angiogenesis, which was reassuring based on the phenotypic
findings we had found.
And then when he looked across all of these diverse gene profiles that were
turned on in a cancer-specific manner,
he could then make a Venn diagram and see which were the common and preserved
factors. And it turns out that only a single gene is
uniquely and consistently dysregulated in the presence of cancer.
And this is an angiogenic cytokine known as LRG1.
Now, I won't have time to show you the data, but he has now gone on to look
upstream of this, and using a variety of
informatics approaches and proteomics approaches, he's found that
this is likely due to increases in TNF secretion by the
tumor. The TNF leads to this angiogenic cytokine, and
he believes that this is leading to the increase in
neovascularization that he's been observing in vivo.
We wanted to know if this was a mouse-only phenomenon or if this is also occurring
in humans. And so we partnered with our colleagues in Europe,
and looking at cohorts of patients with and without cancer,
we've made several observations that validate the mouse findings.
We've seen that in the UK Biobank, cancer patients have higher levels of
circulating TNF, as you might expect.
Looking in plaque biobanks, we've seen that these people also have higher
levels of this angiogenic factor in the plaque itself.
And you can see this on histology, where LRG is upregulated
if you look at endarterectomy samples taken from patients with cancer versus those
without. And when they do machine learning to look at the
factors that are most strongly associated with the presence of
intraplaque hemorrhage within the plaque, they find that a history of
cancer is one of the strongest predictors following only age,
smoking status, and diabetes.
So having mapped this mechanism, Lingfeng now believes that having
cancer will increase your circulating TNF, which will drive this
angiogenic cytokine in the blood vessel, which will destabilize
the plaque leading to clinical events.
He then wanted to know if we could intervene on this for therapeutic purposes.
So to test this, we were fortunate to be able to use commercially
available TNF inhibitors like etanercept, which are commonly used for
autoimmune
and rheumatological conditions.
And when he does this, he finds that the plaques are not only smaller, but
all of this intraplaque angiogenesis will go away.
Now, you may also be aware that these TNF blockers have a black
box warning because of their ability to induce fluid retention.
So patients with congestive heart failure are not allowed to use these
medicines. So this will limit our translational
use for people that are trying to avoid cardiovascular disease.
But he's also been able to go on and look downstream and using an
shRNA to target the specific cytokine.
He's seeing the same type of benefit where
the angiogenesis is suppressed, and we are now working to make a blocking
antibody against this
target.But as we think about the
likelihood that this should be translated to humans, the question is if
this defect is fixed or if it may be something that we could go
after for translational purposes.
Now, this is where, as Javed pointed out, I was really lucky to get to work
with one of the most talented postdocs I've come across.
I don't know if you feel the same way, Javed.
It's nice to have trainees that are smarter than us.
And Ricky, who was a fellow in the lab and went off to train at MGH before he came
back to UCSF, had this really great idea
to try to address the confounding that is so common in
epidemiological studies, and instead to look at cancers that can be
cured with resection alone, where you're not having confounding from
radiation or chemotherapy. And so he took, for example,
prostate cancer, which often is treated with
resection alone, and he will then say, "I wonder
what's going to happen to the rate of revascularization in the years
before and after the tumor is taken out."
He could look at the rates of MI, PCI, and
CABG in the three years leading up to surgery, have a blanking
period around the time of the surgery to avoid
postoperative complications, and then look at the rates years
after the surgery. Now, prostate cancer is not
one of the cancers that we had found was supposed to
enhance atherosclerosis. So it was no surprise that
once the tumors were taken out, that the rates of revascularization
continued to climb. This makes sense because the patients are getting older.
And so it didn't matter that their cancers came out.
They kept having more heart attacks in the future.
But when he repeated the experiment with colon cancer, which is
one of the cancers that Lingfung had shown would directly drive
atherosclerosis, and he looked at the event rates before and
after the resection, he found that, in fact, after the tumors were
taken out, that the revascularization rates began to fall.
This did suggest that this could be intervened upon,
and that if we can break this link, we might have clinical benefit.
So just to conclude, you've seen this slide from Javed's wonderful
paper. And I love the way that this field of cardio-oncology is
evolving because we've moved beyond the risk factors, we've moved
beyond just treating the cardiotoxicities of chemotherapy and
immunotherapy, and we're now beginning to look at these direct causal
relationships, which I think could be leveraged for
translational purposes.
We are actively pursuing this because we know that these aren't just the two
leading killers in the world. They don't just simply share risk factors and
overlapping biology. But because of their causal relationships,
we think that these can lead to new therapeutics.
So I'd like to thank the group that did the work, including Lingfung, who's here in
the audience, and I'll be happy to take questions now or perhaps
in the Q&A.
Thank you.
We can take some questions now.
Sorry, I hope it wasn't that boring.
This may be a dumb question, but do animals that have
excessive p53 expression, i.e. elephants that don't
get cancer, do they have a
reduction in cardiovascular disease?
That's a great question. I don't know that that model has been
studied in atherosclerosis. Lingfung, are you familiar with that?
Yeah, I'm not sure that we've looked.
Yeah, I don't know.
Yes, Donald.
Actually, it was fantastic. As you know, there's a lot
of studies recently looking at the early incidence
of colorectal cancer. The average age for colorectal cancer has gone way,
way down.
Yeah.
And a lot of people think that this is due to changes in the microbiome of things.
But actually, just looking at your data in the two-way talk between the
cardiovascular disease
and cancer risk, I'm wondering if it's
basically changes in diet related that impact that axis
somehow. These patients are way too young to have established
cardiovascular disease, but they may have early onset
cardiovascular disease because
hypercholesterolemia
is a ravage now in younger people.
Yeah. We've been looking at different cancer models, but also different
dietary and environmental insults.
We haven't perturbed the microbiome per se in this, but it's certainly one of the
possible explanations for these earlier and earlier incidents of colon cancer.
But diet and the other risk profile certainly is changing in our population,
and I wouldn't be surprised if it's playing a role.
But I'm actually even asking a more direct question, and
that is: Is there such thing as early onset atherosclerotic
disease that could actually impact the pathobiology of the cancer?
Oh, yeah. We know that we're all getting atherosclerosis from our teenage years.
That was seen in the Korean War, where these people that were killed in action,
I think there was a paper where three-quarters of them had flow-limiting CAD in
their 20s.
Wow.
Now, maybe they smoked more than we do nowadays, but otherwise, they're probably
healthier. They probably had more physical fitness than we do as a population.
So this is a
decades-long process, and as you say, if these other
environmental factors are changing, it's probably accelerating the
overlap.
And then the second question I have is, I'm really delighted I came because
your slide on efferocytosis. We have a paper coming out on
efferocytosis in cancer right now, because it turns out that
estrogens actually are pro-efferototic.
They actually induce efferocytosis, and that's a side effect of
anti-androgen therapy is to actually inhibit efferocytosis.
I'm wondering if this plays into the cardiovascular protective effect of estrogens.
Yeah. Well, we'll have to talk more.
Follow-up, just a question that Donald had.
In terms of the effect of atherosclerotic
factors secreted, probably affect even more compared to
tumor, because as you show data,
the atherosclerosis products
risk factors are even higher
because their systemic factor secreted by the plaques,
probably the total amount will be more than tumor.
Probably you can have five-centimeter tumor, depending on how many factors can
secrete from tumor into systemic factor.
So what do you think in terms of the balance, if you
have cardiovascular disease, atherosclerotic plaques affect
the secreted, like protein C, like other inflammatory
factors affect and promote the tumor growth, it's even probably higher than
tumor to plaques.
Yeah. If I think I understand your question,
Ling Feng has been looking at each of the different factors that we can perturb.
We've been looking at young versus old mice.
And one of the key experiments is dyslipidemic versus wild-type mice.
Everything is accentuated in dyslipidemic mice, but you can also see the pattern in
normal cholesterolemic mice as well. I don't know why it's worse.
Is it the inflammatory side effects that are happening?
Could it be the estrogen signaling as well?
We don't know the exact biology yet, but it is exacerbated
under dyslipidemic conditions.
Yeah. It's interesting you look at it, don't eat me singular in the
plaques. Because in the plaques, there's lots of synaptic cells.
So the synaptic cells prevent eat me
singular or because the plaques is from
macrophages form cells. So do you want
M1 type macrophage or you want more M2 type
macrophage in the plaques? So I sort of M1 to eat the
macrophage more than the M2.
Yeah. It's a complicated literature.
It's probably more than we can tackle here.
The M1, M2 dichotomy actually inverts in cancer versus atherosclerosis.
It's probably oversimplified to try to put them in those two boxes.
And then when they're lipid-laden, their phagocytic capacity also changes.
So I'd be curious to get Catherine's take on this.
The dogma about the different phenotypes is much more complex than the
pro-resolving phenotypes, but I'd be happy to talk to you afterwards about this.
Will do.
Thank you.
Thanks so much, Nick.
It's my great pleasure to introduce Catherine Moore, who is at
NYU and head of Cardiovascular Research Institute there,
who will give us another aspect dimension to what we've been
talking about. Catherine.
Thank you.
As we've been hearing, cardiovascular disease and cancer are the
two leading causes of death,
not only in the U.S. but worldwide.
And
this growing burden of the two diseases is
we typically think of being associated with aging.
But as Donald
asked in the question period, we're also
seeing a striking rise both in cardiovascular
disease and cancer in young adults.
The increase in cancer, colorectal cancer in those
aged less than 40 has been discussed a lot today.
But also
relevant is this increase in cardiovascular disease in
those young adults. And this means that there is a
combined burden that we're seeing in
younger people with a long survivorship.
And this increase in young adults may be
due to shared risk factors, which we've heard about, such as obesity,
hyperlipidemia, and diabetes. These also continue to
rise globally, but I think we've also come to
recognize this complex bidirectional relationship
between cardiovascular disease and cancer.
Nick very nicely showed us that cancer can
increase the risk for heart disease,
both atherosclerotic cardiovascular disease and, as we've
heard from others,
heart failure.
And as this increased risk in cancer survivors has been
recognized, we and others have become interested in what happens
in this survivor population when they have a
cardiovascular event. Can a cardiovascular event, like a
myocardial infarction or a stroke, increase the risk
for cancer recurrence and worsen prognosis?
And as you'll hear today, there is increasing evidence that
this is true, which has led to this new field of reverse
cardio-oncology.
We began to see hints of this in the literature, as Nick mentioned,
approximately a decade ago, with studies showing that heart failure
patients had increased risk of developing cancer.
Initially, these were small studies that the
findings held true in larger cohorts, where heart failure
patients were seen to have increased risk of all types of cancer except for
prostate cancer. There were also
findings of higher incidence of new onset cancer within one
year after a heart attack. And now
studies have emerged with longer follow-up of 17 years showing higher
malignancy risk in acute coronary syndrome patients and worse
prognosis. But cardiovascular disease patients undergo
increased medical surveillance, and this increased risk could come
from detection bias.
However, these observational studies are now being
reinforced with mechanistic studies in preclinical mouse
models that support heart tumor interactions.
The
first such study was published from Rudolph De Beer's group in
2018, where he showed
thatHeart failure increased tumor
growth in a colorectal mouse model, the Apcmin
model, and they did a very interesting study where they transplanted the
failing hearts into the neck of
naive mice and showed that it was actually secreted factors from
the failing heart that were driving this heart tumor interaction.
We've also seen a number of other studies that have identified cardiac
secreted factors such as periostin, nerve growth factor, and
exosomes that seem to interact with the tumor to
stimulate proliferation. I'm going to be talking today about some of our
own work, looking at ischemic cardiovascular events
and how they can reprogram the immune system to be
pro-tumorigenic.
We began studying this in the setting of breast cancer, which is the most common
cause of cancer worldwide. And as Javed mentioned, in the
US alone, there are four million breast cancer survivors.
Like other cancer survivors, they are at significantly increased
risk of cardiovascular disease, and this graph on the right shows the
cumulative incidence of cardiac events in
women enrolled in NCI-sponsored neoadjuvant trials.
And the graph is stratified by baseline cardiovascular risk.
So how many cardiovascular risk factors did these women have
at diagnosis? And in the red line, you can see the
sobering
news that women with multiple cardiovascular risk factors at
diagnosis, 50% of them had had a cardiac
event by seven years
into their cancer journey.
And we wondered, what happens to these women when they
have a myocardial infarction or a stroke?
Does this impact their cancer? And we were surprised to find that no one had looked
at this. So together with Kaiser Permanente, we performed a
retrospective analysis of two prospective
case cohort studies, the Lace and Pathways
population studies, in which 4,000 breast cancer patients had been
followed for 12 years. We found that in women with
no prior history of cardiovascular disease, those that
experienced a cardiovascular event had a 60% increased
risk of recurrence, and when their cancer came back, a
60% increased risk of cancer-specific mortality.
And this was after adjustment for age at diagnosis, race, tumor stage,
menopausal status, smoking, BMI, and treatment.
And on the right, you can see the associated
Kaplan-Meier curves,
with the women that experienced a cardiovascular event in red, showing the
decrease in disease-free years and decrease in survival.
So what are the mechanisms underlying this relationship?
To address this, we
generated a mouse model of combined myocardial
infarction and orthotopic breast cancer,
where the E0771 mammary cancer cells were
implanted into the mammary fat pad.
Three days later, we performed an LAD ligation,
a ligation of the coronary artery that simulates myocardial
infarction or a sham surgery. And then we followed tumor
growth over 20 days. And you can see in the mice that experienced MI,
this red trace, we had a doubling in tumor volume over the
course of our study. And when we stained those tumors for
Ki-67, a marker of cell proliferation, we saw
a doubling of proliferating cells in the tumor border,
and these cells were both immune cells and tumoral
cells.
To ensure that this was not model specific, we repeated our studies in
the MMTV PyMT mouse model that
Donald mentioned earlier. These mice develop palpable tumors
at 15 weeks of age,
approximately. And when we could
detect palpable tumors, we performed the MI or sham
surgery. And again, we see this doubling of
tumor growth after MI.
Because most breast cancer patients don't die of their
primary tumor, but of metastasis, we performed
studies in the E0771 metastatic model,
where tumor cells are
inoculated into the tail vein of C57 black 6 mice.
We again initiated the LAD ligation or
sham surgery and followed
the lung metastasis over time. And you can see here on
the right that we had an increase in mice with metastatic
foci in the lung, and as well as an increase in
tumor to healthy lung area.
So to begin to look at the mechanisms that were
driving this MI-induced tumor growth advantage,
we
looked at the tumor immune microenvironment.
We isolated the tumors at day 20 and performed
flow cytometry and RNA sequencing.
We found that the tumors from mice that experienced MI
had an increase in
CD45 positive immune cells. And looking at the myeloid
population, although we saw no changes in
Ly6G positive neutrophils or Gr-1 negative
macrophages, we saw an increase in
this population of Ly6C high monocytic cells
that resemble MDSCs.
In the lymphocyte compartment, we had an overall
decrease in CD3 positive cells.
And while there was no change in numbers of CD8 positive
or CD4 positive T cells, we saw this
increase in the number of CD4 positive cells that also
expressed FoxP3, a marker of regulatory T
cells.And this suggests that after
myocardial infarction, we were seeing this shift
towards immunosuppression with enrichment of the tumors
in myeloid-derived suppressor cells and regulatory T cells.
To look more closely at this, we isolated the Ly6C high
monocytic cells from the tumors and performed
co-culture assays with naive CD8 T cells.
After three days, we saw no difference in T cell
proliferation, but when we looked at markers of T cell
activation, we found that the MDSCs
isolated from MI mice were more effective
at suppressing T cell activation compared to their
sham counterparts.
Here we're looking at interferon gamma expression, granzyme B expression,
markers of T cell activation. We've also looked at TNF alpha and see
very similar results. And this suggests that on a per cell
basis, these MDSCs are more immunosuppressive.
And this was
reinforced by our
RNA sequencing of these MDSCs from the tumors where after
MI, we found broad gene expression changes
and particularly reductions in expression of
genes involved in the immune response.
When we looked at pathway analysis of these genes that were altered,
we see that they are ones involved in lymphocyte
activation, cytokine mediated signaling pathways, adaptive
immune system, and interferon gamma
signaling. All pathways that are required to mount an
anti-tumorigenic immune response.
So we knew that these MDSCs in the mice after
MI seem to be functionally different, but are they required for the
MI-induced tumor growth advantage?
To address this, we used Ccr2 depleter mouse.
This is a mouse that expresses diphtheria toxin receptor from the
Ccr2 locus, and this allows us to deliver diphtheria
toxin and deplete the Ly6C high monocytic
cells. We chose to do this depletion on day 10.
This was
seven days after the
MI, which is when cardiac healing has
largely been completed.
And on the bottom, you can see this four group comparison.
In the circles are wild type mice, the sham and
the MI mice, where you can see the doubling of tumor growth.
And in the triangles, those where the Ly6C high
monocytes were depleted. And you can see that once these
Ly6C high monocytes are depleted, we completely lose the MI-induced
tumor growth advantage, and we also change the tumor immune
microenvironment.
Shown here in red, you can see that with this depletion,
we have a reduction in FoxP3 positive Tregs, an
increase in CD8 T cells in the tumors,
and an increase in CD8 T cells expressing
markers like granzyme B. And this suggests that these Ly6C
high monocytes that appear to be functionally changed by
the MI are altering the tumor
immune changes.
Given the timeframe of these experiments where the MI
is happening three weeks before
the changes that we're finding in the tumors,
we wondered if the MI could be imprinting innate immune
memory on the bone marrow.
And to look at this, we performed a bone marrow transplantation
experiment where we used our
EO771 model that by now you're familiar with,
where we performed MI or sham surgery.
And then after 21 days, we isolated the bone marrow from these two
groups of mice and transplanted it into naive mice, allowed them
to recover for four months, and then implanted
EO771 tumors.
And we found that in mice that received the bone marrow
from MI mice, there was again this doubling
of tumor growth. So these mice haven't experienced a heart attack
themselves. They simply have bone marrow from mice that have.
And this was sufficient to confer this tumor growth
advantage.
I don't have a lot of time to go into the mechanistic studies that we
performed, but when we look at the bone marrow that was taken here at
21 days,
we performed ATAC sequencing and found broad
chromosomal
accessibility changes in the
monocytes. So we saw many loci that were
less accessible, as well as loci that had
increased accessibility. And
when we performed pathway analysis, again, we're seeing that these loci are
ones that are essential for mounting an anti-tumoral
immune response.
And we could look for transcription factor motif enrichment
in these regions of less accessible chromatin, and
the
most enriched transcription factors that we found were ones like
PU.1 and C/EBP, which are pioneer factors for macrophage
identity, as well as IRF8. And this was
particularly interesting because IRF8 knockout mice
have monocytes that take on an MDSC-like
phenotype.So,
these findings were very exciting because it suggests that the MI
is imprinting a memory on the bone marrow that is
then affecting the hematopoietic stem and progenitor cells
and long-term antitumor immunity.
Since that time, we've been able to address a number of outstanding
questions. The first one was, is this breast cancer specific
or does this happen in other cancers as well?
And here I'm showing you data that we generated in collaboration
with Jesse Dahlman and Christina Angeles at University of Michigan,
looking at melanoma patients that have had either an
ischemic cardiovascular event following diagnosis, MI
stroke, or coronary artery disease versus those that are
cardiovascular event free.
And here you can see again that those
cancer patients that experience ischemic cardiovascular
events have greatly reduced survival.
And we can also perform similar studies in our mouse models
here using the YUM 1.7 melanoma line,
where we see again that MI doubles the rate of
melanoma growth and tumor weight at
sacrifice.
Given the findings by other groups that cardiac secreted factors
also play a role in the heart tumor
interactions, we were very interested in understanding whether
non-cardiac ischemia also accelerated tumor growth.
And here we're using a model of peripheral artery
disease, the hindlimb ischemia model,
where the femoral artery is tied off.
And very similar to what I showed you with myocardial infarction,
the hindlimb ischemia increases tumor growth.
And when we look in the tumor microenvironment, we see by now a very familiar
pattern of an increase in
monocytes, neutrophils, and macrophages, and these
regulatory T cells. And this suggested to us
that this may be a tumor-agnostic
effect that we were seeing that is driven in the bone
marrow.
Since then, we've had the opportunity to perform
multi-omic analysis of bone marrow progenitors, where
we've performed single-nucleus ATAC-seq combined with
single-nucleus RNA sequencing.
Here you can see the UMAP
of our bone marrow,
and we've identified the earliest progenitors, the
HSPCs. We have seven myeloid progenitor
populations and four lymphoid progenitor populations, as well
as megakaryocyte-erythroid progenitors.
And looking first at the single-nucleus ATAC-seq, we were struck
by this finding that the differentially accessible peaks
mostly seem to be in the myeloid progenitors,
shown in yellow here. Sixty-eight percent of the
increased accessible peaks were found in the myeloid
progenitors, and 57% of those that were less accessible are
found in the myeloid progenitors.
And among the myeloid progenitors, in purple,
this group of
NLRP3-positive monocyte/dendritic cell
progenitors seem to predominate.
NLRP3 is a component of the inflammasome that
is critical for maturation of interleukin-1 beta.
Looking at gene expression analysis from the same experiment,
we can look across the progenitor populations
and look at specific gene changes, and focusing
here on the last line, which is the NLRP3-positive MDPs that I was just
talking about. Some of the genes that we are particularly
interested in are NLRP3 and the
interleukin-6 receptor. And we're now looking at the
effects of these two pathways in the reprogramming
of the
myeloid progenitor populations after ischemic injury.
In conclusion, I've shown you that cancer survivors who
experience cardiovascular events have increased risk of recurrence and
cancer-specific death.
In mouse models, we've found that MI and also
hindlimb ischemia accelerates tumor growth and metastasis by enriching
the tumor microenvironment with immunosuppressive myeloid cells and
regulatory T cells.
MI seems to imprint this innate immune memory in bone marrow progenitors
that drives cross-disease communication to alter
antitumor immunity, and this is something that persists
long term.
And in conclusion,
cardiovascular events
should not be considered isolated comorbidities in cancer
patients. We're showing that they can actively reprogram
systemic immunity to promote tumor progression, highlighting
a critical need for integrated cardio-oncology risk
stratification and intervention.
And I'll end here by thanking the people that did this work,
particularly the bolded members of my lab here, my
collaborators at NYU,
and outside NYU, and my funding. And thank you very much for
your attention.
Thank you. Amazing talk. I was wondering if you
can make any comments about the effect of COVID
on
increase in prognosis in cardiovascular disease, especially among the
young, even athletes that we have
seenI know we see that a lot in firefighters,
very young,
athlete, and very active that after they
had COVID, then they developed a cardiovascular disease.
The microphone was going in and out, but I think your question was about COVID
and cardiovascular disease.
That's also a fascinating topic. And
actually, I participated in a study from NYU, from Chiara
Genorelli's group, where we looked at
SARS-CoV-2 virus and its ability to
infiltrate atherosclerotic plaques.
And we found that the SARS-CoV-2 virus could be
detected in the lipid-filled macrophages within the
plaques. And although this wasn't a productive infection,
the virus clearly could get there.
It preferred to be in a nice lipid-rich environment.
And it increased inflammation.
And so I think that it is one of the
contributing factors to the increase in cardiovascular
risk and risk of events that you see in post-COVID.
I'm Dr. Lim from Taiwan, and it's very
interesting to listen to the comprehensive about the
cardiovascular disease induced and
cancer growth.
And I wonder if there is
such as a--
Because some of the study they have implied that the
inflammation induced cancer formation and cancer
progress, and some also emphasize the hormone
and dyslipidemia may contribute the cancer
growth.
Mm-hmm.
Although today's talk is focused on cardiovascular
disease, maybe this
cholesterol imbalance or dyslipidemia
or including inflammation contribute to cancer
formation instead of the cardiovascular
disease.
I think it's a very complex
interaction that we're talking about.
Cardiovascular disease is multifactorial.
We know that we have many risk factors that
hyperlipidemia can increase
risk of both. In my mouse models,
we were not using hypercholesterolemic mice, so
we started by looking first at normal
cholesterolemic mice, mice without vascular disease, so they don't have
atherosclerosis, so that we can begin to isolate these different
pieces and how they affect cancer.
Katherine, thanks for a great talk. I'm going to ask a two-part question.
One is:
Is the effect on the tumor propagation of
tumor that exists there, or is it de novo
tumor formation? I know that's a loaded question.
The second part is: How does the immune remote
programming happen? Is it the hypoxic insult to the
muscle or--
I know those are all probably yesing questions on both
ends.
So your first question's an interesting one.
In our original studies, we implanted the tumor three
days before the cardiovascular event.
And now we've had an opportunity to go back and
play around with the timing. And we see both for the hind limb ischemia
and for the LAD ligation, that it doesn't matter whether
the tumor is present or
what order we put these in. If the MI happens
first and the tumor cells are seeded later, or tumor
cells seeded and then the MI later, we're seeing the same reprogramming, the
same growth advantage that's being given.
We do want to use models, for example,
where
we might be able to
implant tumors, use immunotherapy to
restrict them, and then use an intervention
like a myocardial infarction or ischemic event.
And I think there are multiple variations of that that we could do that would be
very interesting. Certainly, in the patient populations,
these are cancer survivors that we're looking at.
Practical question.
This will be to all the speakers, I guess.
As a medical oncologist or a cardiologist who would be
seeing patients regularly,
if you had an ideal world, unlimited resources and
time, and program
control,
what would
be a recommendation that you would
say if all the people that were taking care of patients right now,
what would be the recommendations for how we should
handle
patients with cancer, not just the breast,
and how should we identify cardiovascular
risk factors as an oncologist? And as a cardiologist,
how should we identify
other crosstalk things?
I think that is the question, because
the reason I got interested in this area was because my mother and my sister
are both breast cancer survivors, and I myself have faced
challenges and undergone a lot of screening.
And one of the things that is, I think, apparent
to most physicians
and to patients is that patients will develop
cancer, and
if they survive, when they survive, they're
followed for a while by their oncologists.
But the continuity of care,
theThe recognition that they should be followed
closely by cardiologists as well, I think
needs to be implemented more strongly and vice
versa. This knowledge that cardiovascular
events can increase
cancer incidence and progression, I think is not
as well
spread as we would hope. And I think that there needs to be better
integrated care where both groups of patients are being followed,
both by cardiologists and oncologists or cardio
oncologists that
follow.
So I have a question that will dovetail onto that.
So, obviously a lot of patients with breast cancer are treated with
radiation,
and there's a very strong focus on being sure that we-- I'm
a radiation oncologist at University of Michigan--
that we spare the heart.
And so that only low dose scatter may be what
affects the heart, if that even has an issue.
But my question is,
are there specific concerns regarding for those patients who do
have heart and radiation induced atherosclerotic disease
and downstream tumorigenic effects?
Does it make a difference how you get the atherosclerosis?
This is probably a better question for Nick, but in the
atherosclerosis field, there is a large
literature of radiation induced changes in atherosclerosis,
and
acceleration.
But in terms of the model of the downstream tumorigenic effects,
that's the piece that I'm really asking about.
Right.
I'm not sure what Nick would say,
but I'm of the camp that if you accelerate
atherosclerotic plaque progression,
this
typically occurs through an increase in
inflammation that drives plaque burden as well
as risk of rupture. And so
I don't think it matters how you're accelerating plaque
progression. I think that many roads can lead to this,
including things like chronic inflammation and
viral infections that can give bursts of inflammation that will
accelerate atherosclerosis and risk of events, and then those,
in turn, may impact underlying cancer.
Thank you very much.
Thanks to all the speakers and happy
to chat. Thanks
for
coming.
Thank you.
Thank
you.
Thanks.